all right well as lippert censorship now
making its way to Canada a Canadian
broadcaster under fire for removing this
cameo of President Trump from home alone
- she's me Bobby down the hall into the
lemon thanks great part the channel
claims the movie was edited to allowed
for commercial time and was not
political however the president just
mentioned the movie while talking to
troops on Christmas Eve the movie they
don't see me on television to say but as
it doing the movie but it's been a good
movie in that I was a little bit younger
to put it mildly and speaking of
holidays movies we all love those
delightfully cheesy but endearing
Hallmark Christmas movies but the Grinch
is at salon.com are trashing them as
quote fascist propaganda right Dana we
have to start with a home alone to love
the movie to better than one I love it I
love ya I like to a slightly better than
one mostly because when I moved to New
York then I could see all of the
different areas and I realized you know
just how special it was I love the baby
so yes this this CBC is saying when they
bought the rights to the movie and had
to be made for television and so that
part got cut but it reminds me of do you
remember when all of a sudden president
Trump's Twitter account went down and he
was the only one it always seems to go
in one direction against President Trump
it sure does I mean the whole Wikipedia
thing where they changed it on the home
alone to saying that impeachment blah
blah blah so liberal censorship versus
content editing I don't really know but
it does seem quite convenient
Jesse homework pulled an ad because the
viewers said that they opposed the ad
they didn't like something about the ad
and then there was an a writer for
salon.com that called hallmark movies
holiday moves in general just fascist
propaganda now here's the problem I have
with this mark itself has
historically been a channel based on
religious shows in the last several
decades it was all religious showings
and
it's gone down down and down is it
really fascist propaganda to have
Christmas movies in the time of
Christmas in a channel that has
historically been religious I mean I
don't care what salons does and fascist
propaganda because it has family values
it's just a ridiculous attack back to
home alone to probably one of the most
underrated sequels ever
Kevin had better booby traps
Harry and what's-his-name Marv bigger
rolled it did a hundred and seventy five
million dollars at the box office it's
on Disney Plus now I just saw it with my
twins they love the Trump cameo that was
one of the most interesting parts of the
movie it was a liberal edit if you want
to edit for time take out the crazy
pigeon lady in Central Park
I hated that woman so and then so when
you when you look at what they did its
rewriting history because what Trump was
in the early nineteen yeah he was a
tycoon that was admired and embraced by
American culture by Hollywood by the
entertainment industry this was a
family-friendly film and liberals can't
accept that so they want to deny it and
it just makes them look petty well and
to be honest with you the Prime Minister
of Canada had blackface on around this
time like you that they're embarrassed
by Trump but not a blackface real quick
to defend Canada for just a hot minute
because I love Canada and I do actually
love the CBC I've been on the CBC etc
etc but I would say this to assume the
Canada a super liberal and the CBC is by
you know sort of default I think it's
wrong if you took it take a look at
Western Canada and the Prairie prime
places like Alberta which is not a
Prairie State but our province and some
of these ask Allah etc Manitoba they're
not necessarily liberal so to blanketly
say canada's liberal is I think
erroneous now let me talk about homework
for a hot minute where I mean where I
think that they're saying like about it
being quote-unquote fascist it's not
necessarily because of Family Values
things but more about the fact that you
know everyone somehow ends up marrying a
prince it's like he was the janitor but
secretly he's a prince and so now like
we're espousing certain values but it's
just fun people we don't need to make
everything political well
that the writer Amanda macro actually
called heteronormative whiteness but
what I found extremely well okay this
proves my point
but what I thought about what I find
interesting is Hillary Clinton took out
an hour-long ad on homework in 2006 when
she for her primary and she it was do
this whole town hall so is it just
convenient at that time Michael or do
you think that it's just now evolving
about a decade ago is okay to be
heteronormative whiteness by Hillary
Clinton on this channel here's what
here's what I know the liberals will
never give up they'll never give up and
they'll always go oh create your own
thing if you want to do that create your
own thing well here at Hallmark where
they've created a space where it's boy
meets girl boy loses girl boy gets girl
it's really that simple these movies
have happy endings
they're just fun there's no big twist
the bad guys don't win and that's
comforting and good and hopefully
there's always room for that kind of
entertainment especially during the
holiday season like it's okay to have
some feel-good television evidently not
the people at saloon comm that's what
they're called now so lucam for all the
heavy drink and they do when they need
stories so I'm gonna call Nazis in
hallmark the same eggnog too much egg
dog saloon writers yes